tell us a little bit about Lewis wolf
and his journalistic publications who is
Lewis and what has he been doing over
the years and why is the government so
outraged by him
well his background is it's thoroughly a
legitimate standard if you will
journalism it was a sign for a couple of
years in Manchester writing for a couple
of prominent news organizations and
England yes Manchester England and
eventually made his way through London
back to the United States where he
gravitated to a scrutiny of the CIA and
the intelligence community watching the
revelations of the Church Committee
information that he had come across in
his research some of which he had
published as part of news stories
previously other parts of which he was
not permitted to publish by the nature
of the press establishment and so he put
together with Bill shap and Ellen Rea
the covert action information bulletin
whose function was to focus on the
intelligence organizations of the United
States and discuss and expose in a
perfectly legitimate way the covert
action activities of the CIA
principally as well as the other
intelligence organizations
I believe they formed that in about 1976
and have been in Washington since
publishing stories of true stories their
quality their standards of journalism
are exceedingly high that bulletin is
distributed in the State Department and
it's sold out the first morning that
it's put on the stands in the State
Department newsstands they also publish
in that bulletin the names of CIA agents
and where they are now as they're
assigned and reassigned about the world
I believe that in very recent months
they have ceased the policy of
publishing names because the controversy
is so hot and they were just too soon
and and also it's never been their
intention to break the law they've made
that clear from the outset
bill shap is the brother is a highly
competent attorney and is the brother of
top sportscaster in New York City he is
a very articulate man himself and has
testified to the Senate many times
against the names of agents bill for
example and and defending what he and
Lew will for doing and after his
testimony many times senators have come
up and shaken his hand and said I
disagree with you but you certainly make
your case for the legitimacy of what
you're doing very well
yes let's yeah let's take a look at some
of the things which Lewis wolf had to
say and we'll let you comment ever so
often on glass okay what in the years
that you've been publishing it you think
are some of your most significant
revelations I there's some stories that
even shocked you well I think one of the
big stories that we were able to
document in some detail was the the rent
the whole scope of CIA activities
similar to what the CIA did in Chile in
which was documented by the Senate
Select Committee was the whole covert
action program in Jamaica in between
1976 and 1980 and we were we did a great
deal of research into that and we
discovered many in many ways a very
similar program almost a classic model
that was followed along the lines of
what they did in Chile including three
major categories military power military
activity the use of propaganda in the in
the media and the third one which was
economic warfare using the multilateral
organizations the International Monetary
Fund and others to withhold loans which
had been promised to that you make in
government this is one example what I
cut them were the details of that you
particularly mention those first two
examples of actual paramilitary activity
well CIA was involved in in Jamaica
there was a fire for example that took
place in Jamaica of an old people's home
I think 150 old and infirmed women many
of them blind we're living in this home
and as it turned out the place burned
down in the space of about eight minutes
seven or eight minutes it was discovered
that the phone wires had been cut and
that their exits had all been blocked
even those who could see their way out
could not get out and that the means by
which the fire was set was the use of a
petroleum jelly which was unavailable in
Jamaica this was one indication among
others that there was outside help why
was why would the CIA you might ask why
would the CI want to murder
150 old women it was because it was an
effort part of a very large-scale effort
to discredit the government in Jamaica
which was at the time headed by Michael
Manley the prime minister there were
images produced of Michael Manley in the
media in the Daily Gleaner which was the
newspaper which the United States
through the CIA helped to support and
there is a good deal of evidence of that
there were images of Michael Manley
showing a death mask I mean was his face
which had been somehow made to look like
a death mask although it was pretending
to be a photograph of him and there were
many ways to try and discredit him this
is very very similar in fact to what the
CIA did to try and discredit Salvador
Allende in Chile if you remember Richard
Nixon instructed CIA in a meeting which
was in 1970 in the White House and there
was a document in the Senate report
which is reprinted and he said make the
economy scream those were his words and
that's of course what the CIA proceeded
to do in Chile and that's what they also
did in Jamaica they also had furnished a
lot of munitions and assistance to the
terrorists squads that were going around
people in in those cities and also in
the countryside in Jamaica as well
that's correct
well John you had a trip down to Jamaica
and you saw a lot of these things about
Jamaica with your own knives right yes
indeed very moving a very interesting
trip to me to see a target country at a
time in the height of a CIA operation
when I was completely outside so there's
no way that I could see to see the
problem that journalists have always had
when the US government was targeting on
a country in a situation trying to
destabilize it overthrow or manipulate
the elections or whatever of trying to
figure out what's going on when you
don't have access to all of the flow of
cables and the discussions and National
Security Council meetings and whatnot
for the planning I observed that from
published information a CIA station
there was quite large for that size of a
country it was huge in fact it was
bigger than any station I knew of in
Africa although Jamaica was a fairly
small island with two million people
that's typical of when the CIS is got a
big operation going in a place they
beefed up the station and beefed up the
offices back stateside the tone and flow
of articles in The Gleaner was of course
as Lou says definitely a chapter out of
Chile or a chapter out of the Angolan
operation every indication of a massive
CI operation going to destabilize the
government to make the economy screen
and in that case I would say that
probably someone got promoted for that
one probably several people because
Manley was right because it worked by a
legitimate yeah without without a
scandal without an assassination without
the things that have caused the CI so
much grief a manly a champion of social
democracy of giving the people a piece
of the pie I was thrown out of office
and an arch capitalist
I was put in office and and again there
was a minimal adverse publicity lure
wolf and the others were studying the
situation and did publish about what was
going on but it was not published in the
New York Times in the Washington Post
and the big the big television networks
didn't do Studies on it primarily
because even if the journalists of the
big organs knew what was happening and
might have wanted to they really just
because of the secrecy couldn't get the
truth about what the United States was
doing one interesting thing was that the
effectiveness of the lies the liars in
our government you know the duplicity
when we form the CIA we committed our
leaders to having two policies as loose
as the rhetoric the public statements
and the truth about what the United
States policy is so an interesting
measure of presidents is how effectively
they lie interesting discussions that
occur inside the CIA is about lying
would would you lie you know you're the
d-do and you're going to testify to the
Senate and serious discussions are you
going to lie because if you do it's
perjury and there's a chance you could
go to jail and yet you know the
organization expects you to lie the
President Carter was one of the most
effective Liars I have ever watched on
television and through the media as a
poker player men I would never go up a
man he could look at that camera and say
things that obviously he knew were
completely and totally false and I would
study his expression and I could detect
nothing except occasionally a little
wisp of a smile that wasn't consistent
with what he was saying like he thought
it was funny but one of his more prized
attack actually well the the smile that
I was referring to wasn't that it was
just a kind of like he was repressing a
grin like he thought it was funny
how he rationalized these things I don't
know but one of his most
conspicuous lies was when he sat down
with manly just a few weeks before the
elections in Washington and told him
face to face
that the CI don't have the CI doing
anything to destabilize you or your
government we have no such program going
when obviously he did and he pulled it
off to the point where even Manley was
troubled very effective ly liars